hey guys my name is Jess it is the 22nd
of February and a Wednesday which I will
never refer to as hunt day in Hugh's
games what news dust-up I've got some
good news for those of you keen on
picking up a Nintendo switch retailer
Game Stop have announced that they will
have a limited supply of the new
Nintendo console available in store on
launch day but if you want to stroll in
and grab yourself a switch to play on
the toilet like this badass the retailer
recommends attending one of the midnight
launch events as the consoles Wilker
fast the Nintendo switch launches next
week on the 3rd of March for $300 be
sure to stick around for all our
upcoming launch coverage
next up battlefield 1 is getting a bunch
of new weapons as part of its next DLC
packs the upcoming DLC they shall not
pass includes 11 new guns which are
available right now for some players as
part of the community test environment
some variants of existing weapons
although there are three new melee
weapons the nail knife trench blur and
cogwheel Club the new armaments are
earned through challenges such as
getting X amount of kills with different
weapons or reviving or resupplying
teammates the battlefield community test
environment which is the testing server
where features and balance changes are
trialed before being made available
publicly is only accessible for plays
with the battlefield premium pass on PC
third eyes have said they hope to launch
this ETA for ps4 and Xbox one
eventually you can register to be a part
of this ETA via the battlefield
companion app or in game finally here
are the Xbox 360 and Xbox one games
you'll be able to get for free with your
Xbox Live Gold subscription from March 1
you'll be able to grab layers of fear on
Xbox one and Borderlands 2 on 360 via
games with cult be quick vote as
Borderlands 2 is only available until
March 15 when it will be replaced by
heavy weapons on March 16 Xbox one users
can grab evolve for free if you haven't
grabbed fehb spree games with gold
titles you still have time to grab the
Force Unleashed on 360 and love is in a
dangerous space-time and project cars on
Xbox one it's cool I'm done with the
news now you can go do that
that's everything I've got for you today
thanks for sticking around and do leave
us a comment if you like and head to
game slot for our tips on Ghost Recon
wildlands I will see you tomorrow